In this exercise, we start with a square tessellated into a grid of smaller
squares. This grid allows us to deform the surface. Deformation happens in the
vertex shader. What I want you to do is modify the incoming vertex position.
Since this value is passed in, you can't just change it. You'll need to copy it
over to a temporary variable and modify that. You also need to use this
temporary variable in the rest of the shader instead of the position. How I
want you to modify the position is by using this formula. The first half of the
function finds a point on the sphere. The second half translates the whole
object down by a constant amount so that it stays in view. The uSphereRadius2
is a value passed in by the main program. It's the square of the radius set
with the slider. XPOS, YPOS and ZPOS are the position coordinates. To access an
individual value of a vector, use x, y or z. When you're done, you should see
something on the screen that looks like part of a sphere. It's a bit bland and
we'll talk more about this later. Definitely save your work since we'll build
on it.